I'm tired of hearing that he's not well
spoken enough to be the president george
bush wasn't a very good public speaker
but he was also a great president i'm
tired of hearing people say that Ben
doesn't have the experience to lead that
he doesn't have be just the experience
that he's too quiet well he's a very
easy person to listen to he has a voice
that is somewhat mesmerizing I'm kind of
tired of hearing that they don't think
he's intelligent just because in a
manner of speaking it's a little slow
when he speaks but I mean I know he's
very intelligent I believe we can handle
tough situations what am I most tired of
hearing about about dr. Carson um
Kenneth it's almost a conspiracy to not
talk about dr. Carson that you know the
guys second in the polls behind mr.
Trump and his greatest strengths is a
compassion is intellect let's solve
problems with intellect instead of Bruce
brute force and they tend to ignore that
while looking for the dirt he actually
just recently took a trip to Jordan to
talk with and be with the Syrian
refugees and I just think that's
incredible because often we think that
the only way we can help them is just to
bring them over here but he's helping
them by being there we're organizing
things here to send them food things
like that my most passionate
when it comes to ben Carson and politics
in general is abortion there's not
another person in the world I think who
could approach that subject with such
personal belief and passion and care for
those lives that are currently not being
valued and the surgeons the assistants
the nurses and the skilled people he's
worked with all his life are a good team
and he knows how to build a team and he
knows how to build consensus